Queen responds, "I'm telling you that you're behaving exactly
like the type of loser you would farm for a year." Saying attacks
on Willie are gross and a harassment campaign after being totally
dangled on the substance by Auggie. Restrain Queen. Okay, if
I could make him not be totally unhinged, would you talk to him
for two seconds? I'm sure he could walk you through some of the
criticisms he has like in a calm way. >> And so I just
start spam joining like the VC above and the VC below. the one
that Stale talking to Jay stalking just like spamming bouncing
back and forwards between the two and Stale freak out on stream.
No, I'm not going to do that. Sorry. I just think that he shouldn't
be as strange on Twitter cuz he was strange to me. I tried engaging
with him and then it just immediately attack whatever. But yeah,
that's it. That's all I had. I think Sorry, hold on. I
not Richard Hania. This commentary drama sounds seriously
uh Okay. Yeah, I mean it might be. It's little YouTubers fighting
with each >> Let's uh I'll go through these tweets and
we can just get, you know, we can get all the tweets out of the
way and then we watch new tweets come in. We can talk about it
as the night goes on. I usually I was going to read an article
first, but hey, I kind of just want to I kind of just want to
go. I kind of just want to go, you know. So, let's check it out.
We start off with this chain of tweets here. Okay. Earlier earlier
today,
Stardust tweets. Okay. Okay.
Nicholas challenges Drew Pavlo to a debate. Prove to me that
you're not gay and didn't go to a gay bar. Drew now has 24 hours
to respond. That's a meme. Okay. That's a meme. It's nothing
but a meme. Okay. That's But this person who, by the way, I think
this person's like super pro Ethan Klein.
I don't think this person is like um a big Queenman fan or something.
From my impression, I've like I the impression I've gotten is
they actually are like a way bigger fan of Willie and Nick. Okay,
so Nicholas can debate Drew Pavlo, but is running away from all
the smaller creators in his community. Who? I was tweeting this
as a joke. Lol.
I don't know why Stardust said who. She knows exactly who it
is. Wait, what was that bio? Did I mouse over? Hot girls for
Zoran founding member. I think this is the Is this not the black
cat person?
Right. There was like a Twitter account. It was like the black
capper. Is that the same person? I think it's the same person.
Anyway, so they sayqan.
What does he have to what does he have to debate Quean about?
Why he thinks his feud with Tommy is gay? He's already said his
opinion on the Chud Tommy fight and he already tried to get Auggie
to denounce Tommy and got laughed at laughed at. What more could
Nick provide other than being bigger to suck off?
Hold on.
When did
When did Queenman try to get Auggie to denounce Tommy C?
That doesn't sound like it's something that happened. Did that
happen? I've I don't rec I have no idea what this could possibly
be referencing to tell you the truth. Nothing. No clue. I believe
Queman thinks a lot of his Ethan Pine coverage is complete hackery.
For me personally, if one of my quote unquote friends, lol, had
all that criticism for me, I'd be glad to address why they're
wrong. That seems like a totally fair point, right? somebody
you say you respect, somebody you say you you uh you like talking
to,
but apparently not over this. Not taking criticism, guys. Not
taking criticism on this anymore. Okay, we've moved past criticism
on the Ethan Klein on the H3H3 coverage issue. Was an Auggie
challenged with denouncing Tommy C on your stream a few weeks
ago by Aiden. Uh that sounds like it was possible or that sounds
possible, but I just can't imagine Quimman doing it. Quan is
not the kind of guy who's who goes and gets people to like say
you will you denounce this person. Will you say that this was
wrong? They'll just say like, "What do you think about this?"
Or he would say like, "What do you think about this?"
I do think, now that I recall, I do think Aiden did do something
like that, which is a little goofy. Aiden can be a goofy Gus.
Okay. Be a bit of a goofy Gus.
And Nick has said he doesn't care if people want to watch his
EHD coverage. He's enjoying it and that's what he's going to
do on stream or do streams on. He said multiple times that if
you don't want to watch it, don't watch it. Then he times out
whoever's complaining. Um, I don't think any of Quimman's actual
cover or criticism is you cover this too much. Or at least that
would be an incredibly surface and low tier criticism. It is
you're being disingenuous when you cover this stuff, right? You
are not covering it honestly. You are giving you are giving cover
to people and you are covering it in a way that absolutely benefits
the clients. That's the criticism. All right. Thank you very
much, Geeky Candy. Thanks for the support. We'll talk to you
later. Bye. So, let's see. Starters follows up. Exactly. If I
were in the same situation, friend or not, we've come to the
conclusion that you don't like my that's fine. I'm going to keep
doing it because I enjoy it. Again, the criticism is not so low
tier as, hey,
I think you do this too much. It is, I think you are borderline
lying. I think you are disingenuous. I think you are not giving
the right takes and you're you're you're being too soft on the
clients and too harsh on the other people. And it is building
up like a wave against them. Uh, I've I've explained this. So,
this is where Nicholas finally comes in. Okay. Finally comes
in,
participates in the conversation. I've explained this a few times.
Ultimately, I became disillusioned with how my friends were treated
early this year and shifted the entirety of my focus back to
my channel. I closed some lines of communication and intentionally
left some open, but I'm largely unconcerned with what those people
think of me. So, what I what I see here is um he he like blocked
a bunch of people who were in the commentary community, right?
He blocked me. He blocked a couple other people, which like that's
totally fine. I didn't blow him up for that. I was like, I get
it. You feel like you feel like people around me are attacking
you. The funny thing is I had basically stopped any coverage
of like Willie and Nicholas. And I I give like soft defenses
of Nicholas like quite a bit where it was just like, yeah, I
get I get why he's doing this coverage. Like it's it's good money.
It's really good really good viewership, really good money. Makes
a lot of sense to me.
So, I didn't have like any problem with him, but
man, I don't get the the other lines of communication he decided
to close or like stop going on like Chud stream. He kind of like
backed off from this like the Chud Queen Mitten. I guess you'd
say like former Destiny space. I don't even know how to label
it necessarily.
And that just seems like a weird choice. Like I I didn't get
the feeling that anybody there was unfair to him, right? Some
fans were unfair to him. I get I think this mostly gets what
do you call it? This mostly starts and stops with the communities
around this, right? Where the communities around um around Chudder
Queen might be really harsh to certain people and some people
really can't handle that, right?
Seemed odd it coincided with his Ethan coverage. Well, I think
already before even the Ethan coverage had reached its like highest
point, I think a lot of people around, you know, spicy chat or
just Queen and Chud, like a lot of the viewers were like, "Oh,
this is like we're not huge fans of Nicholas, right? But I think
that's that's like it's like a contrarian space. It's it's like
an anti-creator space. It's just funny, right? Like I you can't
take the opinions there personally or you'd like I don't know
implode if you were involved with them at all. But he he didn't
like that and then there was like actual criticism that started
to come out and it started compounding and then I think he just
decided he wasn't going to take criticism from people. wasn't
going to have conversations on it and he moved to just yeah I'm
like going to comment and and not talk to anyone which is just
it's bizarre for like a commentary YouTuber and then to act like
oh the people who do comment on it now the people who do comment
negatively about me or about this coverage they're actually attacking
me they're actually snakes who are going after me for no reason
that's kind of crazy too I doubt he left because he couldn't
handle it okay what other reason do you think there could be
for him leaving Ginger Nick hates you and thinks you and are
the same well I The funny thing is is I think um I don't know
what happened with the the Willie debate that Nick decided like
we were snakes. Like I he said he would talk to me about it and
I was just like, "Yeah, if you want to talk about my coverage."
And then I think later he he he accepted. He said he was going
to come on stream talk to me. And then he actually said, "Never
mind, I'm not going to." And deleted me and left my
which was bizarre.
And I wasn't looking to like debate him or say like, "Oh, I was
totally right." It was just going to be like, hey, um, it was
like totally off the cuff and I didn't verbalize like my complaints
well, but I think like the core the core of my complaints was
solid. Just I I stated them poorly.
But like it's not the end of the world, right? That was the conversation
I wanted to have. Never got to have that conversation and then
other people started going hard on them and yeah, the rest is
history because it gets the it gets ideas that he's above it
and doesn't want to entertain certain people anymore. It's not
the first time. Oh, maybe. Dario, blocked me on X after I retweeted
a tweet critical of Willie. I have a private profile and no followers.
Okay, that's interesting. That's very interesting. There is a
massive is what I hear. Well, man, that's rough.
I So, I think I sort of understand where he's coming from with
some of it. And
I just don't like the misrepresentations. And they're not big,
right? the the misrepresentations he does are not big, but everybody
around him gets the impression that like there's this really
unhinged community that has no valid criticism. They just want
to blow things up for no reason, right? That's sort of the impression
he gives. And I don't think that's fair. And when you constantly
like malign and lie about your critics, then I think that eventually
catches up with you, especially in a community that is about
criticism, right? I am going to watch things critically with
a critical eye and tell you what might be wrong with it. Is that
not the Yes, that exactly only mute. That is the commentary community.
Yes. So, we'll keep reading here. I thought the hyperfixation
on Willie and Tommy was really gross and unfair. Obviously, a
lot has happened since then, but by the time the jerk wave shifted
to me, it was already past me. It's not even really the streamers
as much as militant audience members who feel like they are entitled
to my time. So, he's again, yeah, talking about the audience
here, I guess. Not much else here. All right.
But
listen, this was uh
the hyperfixation stuff. This was a little too much for a certain,
you know,
slight of build person. Okay.
Was a little too much. He was not a fan of these comments. Okay.
Quinn responds, "How can you possibly bring yourself to say something
like the fixation on Tommy and Willie was really gross and unfair
given your content and the you've chairled all year? Totally
shameful." So yes, like the hyperfixation
was really gross and unfair. So you have to say why it's gross
and unfair, right? He doesn't say why it's gross unfair. And
he kind of avoids doing that a lot of the time. Why? Why is it
gross and unfair? That's really important. You just say it's
gross and unfair. Well, okay. So the idea of hyperfixating on
something is gross and unfair. How do you justify going after
Denims, Caseyron,
um Hassan, all of these people, right? Idubbbz,
right? How do you justify that if the hyperfixation is gross?
It seems like the hyperfixation is sort of what defines a lot
of commentary YouTube is you you get storylines and people who
are acting poorly. And often when people act poorly, especially
when they're internet creators, they tend to have a bit of narcissism.
They can admit fault. They constantly spiral and they eventually
explode or implode. Love their careers. Okay, that's like a ton
of what commentary YouTube is. This is all of Nicholas's coverage
on Tipster. This is all of Nicholas's coverage on Boaxs. This
is like a whole bunch of the coverage Nicholas has done in his
career, right? It's very hard to make some sort of moral prescription
here. Queen follows up criticizing commentary YouTubers for their
videos in a really mean way is actually about as fair as it gets.
Cut this out. We the people will not entertain this fence fence
sitting
for one more second. It's a salvo tweet. Wow. Nicholas gives
me the impression of someone who desperately wants to be part
of the cool kids. Uh no, I'd say that's entirely incorrect about
Nicholas.
Um yeah, I don't I don't feel that way at all about him. Um,
I don't think that's actually probably what the what a fair criticism
would be here. Oh man, did I really
did I really Oh god, hold on. So, I believe that Nicholas and
Queen get into an argument here. And I for some reason failed
to grab the exact tweet that I quote tweeted. So, hold on.
They actually get into an argument here. Give me a second. Oh,
I got to break this clip out, which is very nice. You love to
see it. All right. So
Nicholas quote tweets and responds, "If people want to be fixated
with Willie or Tommy, that's their personal prerogative. If I
don't think the criticism is fair or worthwhile, I reserve the
right to not participate and judge people accordingly." Lm fao.
So again, you do have to say why the criticism is unfair. When
he went to go say why the criticism was unfair with his friend
Auggie, okay,
when he went to go say why that criticism was unfair, he totally
failed to make like a tangible point, right? Augie totally right
him over the coals on it.
Hold on. Apparently we should hop into the uh the Agamid space
here. Let's go take a look. >> Think. But right now I'm
against like what he's doing. So I don't know. It's just super
gay. I'm going to let Dude, my my options are like five randoms
and then Courtney. All right, I'm letting in the little owl first.
Courtney, you can come in after the little owl. I've been I've
been making little owl wait. Okay. >> Oh. Oh boy. Courtney,
I know you haven't been following the situation. I know you're
going to come in here and say, "This is [__]
>> give me a second. >> You get second place." Little
owl, I've been making you wait for like 20 minutes. How you feeling?
>> Okay, give me a second until >> uh Yeah, pretty
entertainment. That's >> okay. Hold on, hold on, hold on.
>> How you feeling about everything? Seems like we got
some stuff going at with all
>> I'll start by saying that like I'm not a regular viewer
of Queen and I watched a couple of his streams.
I don't know the situation that well. I to be honest, I've been
disengaged with the H3 stuff for a decent amount of time, but
I don't get this Nick stuff, man. Like, I've disagreed with Queen
a little in the past, but I think he's generally right here.
I don't get this. I don't get the way Nick's react. >> From
what I'm hearing, you're basically where I'm at where I'm at.
I've been like I've been I've been disengaged with the Ethan
stuff for months at this >> you know, and like I'm not
like I've been in Nick's community for years now, right? Like
I don't think I don't think writing me off as some queenite is
just going to be like, "Oh yeah, he's just some psycho." >> But
like I just I don't get angle's coming from if >> like
I I don't get where it's coming
>> with like the if you're not following like the whole
theory that he's just like latching on to someone else. Like
if he's genuinely holding his principles, I don't I don't understand
this. And at the end of the day, I actually want to see this
Queen and Nick debate happen. Not necessarily for just to understand
Nick's perspective, but mostly for content because I think it
could actually be a very entertaining
>> Yeah. I don't get it. I don't like uh I feel like it's
reasonable to say like if you promote a guy for a year, say he's
your friend. >> Like you owe >> And Quan
Quman, I only found out about him because he was obviously promoted
by Nick. That's the only reason I know that he actually exists.
Sorry, queen.
>> who the >> Ryan Wade
>> Stale's in there. Let's go. >> I don't get his
reaction here. And generally, I do tend to agree with Nick on
most things. >> I don't get his reaction here. This just
>> it's it's dodging the conversation. That's what it is.
Let's put it. Yeah. Let's go.
That's the entire By the way,
hold on. Just to be in because I guess Courtney's been following
the situation >> with all of this. Oh, they pulled Queen
out of listener as well. Okay, just to be clear with all this
>> Alex Gekko is like a massive Nick fan. This is all like
Nick's audience here. These like a bunch of people from Nick's
audience. Okay, >> so honestly, >> losing these people
is probably quite bad for him.
because like he has he has a perfect reason to not like
>> want to be talking to queen >> you can
>> he's suck I hope you know I hope you
>> you are
>> you asked did you just call me a yes I >> I was
able to carry I was talking about you when I said the only people
I'm getting in here are I was talking about you directly.
>> you are and you baited me. >> You are a waste
of >> I don't like that you provide [__] >> [__]
Courtney, dude. >> All right,
>> guys. Chris Rainmate says he wants back in and that
he actually has a point. I'm going to give him a second shot.
Okay,
>> if he doesn't say anything >> doesn't say if he
if he comes in here and he says Chris, >> this is going
well. This is going really well. Third redemption. How you >> genuinely
genuinely Aiden is a stupid
>> Chris. I gave you >> disavowed. Disavowed. Disavowed.
>> I I just had to say Aiden is a stupid >> I gave
you a third chance. I not even Jesus does. >> We're going
to go ahead and
kill him.
>> I just I can't believe someone would betray my trust
like that. Cinematications.
Let's let's let Cinematications in. >> Jesus Christ.
>> But I'm a man of the people. Cinematications. How we
feeling? >> Hey, I'm I'm feeling good. Uh I've been like
I've been watching go down and I was talking >> You want
to join? I think I have a request speak request >> a buddy
of mine about the whole like smaggle frogen Nick situation that's
been going on recently where >> but I think uh >> Nick
has just been really uh unfortunately oh man quite frankly rude
about the whole uh Eminem
>> okay I'm actually going to switch back to covering this
stuff okay
go back to covering this stuff we were on the Nicholas tweet
here
we're on uh which Nicholas tweet we're on this one okay
we're we're going to cover this stuff really quickly okay and
then we will go back. We'll we'll listen to the space. If anybody
important in the space gets brought up or if there's a good point,
someone let me know. All right. Well, hold on. I'm actually going
to cancel my speak thing for a second because I'm going to I'm
going to go read the rest of these tweets so I get everybody
gets the context. Okay.
So, Nick quote tweets quote tweets comes back says, "People want
to cover Willie, all these people, they're welcome to do so,
but I just didn't think it was fair or worthwhile to do these
criticisms." Okay. I didn't think these were actually good criticisms.
Was
it Aiden again? I missed it. I What? Aiden's a commentary YouTuber.
Okay. How can you possibly bring yourself to say something like,
"The fixation on Tommy and Willie was really gross and unfair.
People I cover on a daily basis are presented with an opportunity
to do this as well as as well and actively choose to give me
more content. Others will certainly judge me for taking advantage
of that. Their friends may even dislike me. I don't police what
any of these guys say on their own uh own respectively platforms.
They can actually go live and talk about my friends for a trillion
years. 10x my Boax coverage if you have to. The only thing I
did about it was silently shift focus to my own channel instead
of hang out with the people who are doing it.
I mean, you could just come and say like this is why it's unfair,
right? That's the whole thing. the the the thing you do or the
thing you should do if you're about you know open discussion
and open criticism, open commentary is you can just go to the
places where you're allowed to be where you're totally welcome
completely all the time even now totally welcome all the time
right and just say hey this is why I think it's unfair and then
talk about it
and I think mostly people feel like the the reason you wouldn't
talk about it is because the criticism has merit right yeah you
just don't have to do you don't even have to respond or you don't
have to say that it's unfair fair. If you won't say why it's
unfair and then defend that position, then we understand that
you don't really think it's unfair. You just don't like it, which
is again totally your prerogative, but then don't say it's unfair
or gross. Just say I don't like it when my friends get talked.
I don't like it when my friends who have Down syndrome and are
illiterate get talked. That's up. I hate it. I hate when that
happens. That's a totally fair position to have, by the way.
You can totally do that. That's no problem. I think I should
be back live on Twitch as well, guys. Sorry about that. I had
to I had to cancel. I had to I had to restart the stream there.
Little technical glitch, you know. Little technical glitch. All
right, we get Queen and Core tweeting back. But when someone
says, "How can you possibly bring yourself?" They're typically
expressing bewilderment at someone doing something shameful,
not asking how it's physically possible. You're responding, "If
someone called me gross, I'd turn it into content. Is giving
the game away,
right? It's figurative, not literal. You should just be honest
and say his friends can do no wrong." I don't think he thinks
that. I think he's just like his friends can do wrong, but you
have to, you know, you can you can make a comment and then you
have to move on. You can't like demand a response from them.
You can't demand like honesty or or accountability from them.
All you can do is make like one comment and go on. That's it.
That's it. That's it. That's
I'm telling you directly that I think the comm the community's
criticisms of Lily, for example, weren't worthwhile. Some of
them hinged on being completely contrarian. This isn't me giving
the game away. It's just me being honest and saying it's not
really worth my time. So again, he hasn't actually I I just think
this is
this is a perfect example of when you know you don't have a point
or you know you're actually getting like totally ripped in the
conversation, right? Is I will say that it's totally unfair what
you guys did to Willie. But I won't say what was unfair, right?
The best he can do is say me hopping on a stream totally impromptu
to be like, "Hey, I think uh I think Kelly has a point here.
I think you didn't really cover the the heart of the cherry stuff."
like that that oh totally off the cuff hopping in to do that
was like completely unfair and
All it all it would have taken is like one more conversation
to just go oh yeah I think the this is where I misspoke. Here's
probably the real criticism and here's how you would fix it.
It's like not even a problem right
responds. I'm telling you that you're behaving exactly like the
type of loser you would farm for a year saying attacks on Willie
are gross and a harassment campaign after being totally dangled
on the substance by Auggie. So, this is
when you tried to say this is what is bad, Auggie went, "Oh,
come on, man. Really? You really think so? Here's here's like
why I don't think it's bad." And Nick would go, "Well, I guess
that's kind of fair, right?" And that's like the most friendly
fair engagement he'll get on the topic was from Auggie. And Auggie
kind of made him look silly, right? Like the defenses of Willie
were very silly. Uh Nick responds, "I actually am not sure what
you're even trying to argue with." Dangled on the substance by
Auggie. Ultimate. Ultimately, if that's really going to be your
response, then I wish you luck. But this is way too gay for me.
I don't even know what this means.
responds. I'm saying you got
live, buddy.
Damn.
Yeah. So, no engagement, no examples cited. No examples cited
long-term, right? Nothing. Just nothing.
Nothing at all.
I believe I believe there's a very solid quote tweet here with
a good clip. Okay, hold on. This one? Yeah, this one right
This is a good clip. Okay, >> dude. These people deserve.
That's what they And I disavow, but it is what they deserve.
God, it just Yes, we always disavow. Okay, we always disavow.
Queen really doesn't pull punches. Uh, no. It's um It's good
times. We got anything in this space? We got anybody interesting
in here talking? Nope.
Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. Nope. All right.
I think that gets us to the end of this. I don't think there's
a response from Queman. Okay.
Or sorry, I don't think there's a response from Nicholas to Queen
telling him he's getting that he was live.
I think it's it ends there somehow. Somehow someway it just ends
there. We should chat on stream sometime. Oh, based. How did
JF and him do that? Jesus. Yoinking that one. It is a good clip.
I love that clip.
We get anything going in the egg space. Is this >> pretended?
Oh, dude. This girl killed herself because of like what a 15
member snark like subreddit had like 10 posts.
>> Can we also like stop pretending snark snark subreddits
are these like massive evilly things? Sure, like the people on
there are losers, but like they're really not that bad. >> It's
just I think I've heard people say this and it's kind of true.
like it it's just people engaging with their kiwi farms throughout
at this point. It's like like a few years ago everyone has said,
"Dude, you're why are you engaging with this stuff, but now now
it's cool to like cope and cry about the people who are like
saying about you know >> Nick advocating for like the deplatform
of it as well. It's crazy. >> Okay, hold on. Hold on, >> guys.
I'm going to actually end on Twitch just if we're going to cover
a Twitter space. Uh the toos is pretty >> No, he's not
for the deletion of it. I've definitely seen it on the stream.
>> guys. Hutch is not happy. Okay. Hutch is not happy.
>> Old idiot. Dude, the Hutch coverage. People have not
liked the Hutch coverage. Okay. >> Basically, what I've
been going on is >> dude, this is going to be good. This
would be very funny to watch. >> But he is talking to Queen
about it cuz he's not a
>> Thank god.
>> You love to see it >> because he's scared of he's
scared of crashing out in an argument or something like that.
That's what I think. >> Okay. And if that's true, it's
just >> I'm Yeah, I'm gonna end the the Twitch stream and
go just over to Kick, guys.
Sorry. It's just if we're covering a Twitter space, the toss
is scary. >> Can't defend what he's saying. I think uh
that's pathetic and spous. >> Yeah, I think that's why
to be honest. >> It's just I mean it it's just completely
like pathetic to see. I don't know. >> It's very sad to
see. >> If anyone who's pro- Nick would like to call in,
by the way, go ahead. Listen, I'm not anti Dioro as a person.
I'm anti him in this situation. changed my mind. Listen, the
people look people like Cooked Cooked hasn't been following the
situation 100%. Maybe maybe Cooked missed something. Maybe Cooked
>> I literally talked to any of these people about it,
too. >> Going off on Ethan when all this criticism was
negated. >> Okay, maybe that happened and me and Cooked.
We just weren't we didn't see >> Call in. Okay,
>> just one argument could prove us all >> It's true.
Okay, thank you for calling in. There's this guy on space now
>> who's saying on Twitter. I'm gonna let him in now. All
right. >> Oh, we got stale.
Stale.
>> I am a little confused as to why you're confused. So,
reading some of tweets,
>> he what? said he's like annoyed. Like
>> he like what doesn't take you guys seriously. He thinks
it's like bad criticisms. It turns out like that's how real life
works. If somebody doesn't like you, they're not going to give
you your time. Like why? Why is this so
promoted him, promoted him in certain dramas when Cleman was
acting the same towards other people. But when it kind when it
suddenly got turned towards him or in his general direction,
now he's completely avoiding Queen and saying, "Oh, dude, this
guy's not worth engaging with. It's gay." That is pathetic. If
Quimman was so bad Faith and his arguments were so bad, he should
just get on a stream and put it in the mud right now. >> So,
you're saying that he was being attacked when you're So, yeah,
when you're mean to somebody, turns out people don't want to
talk to you. Like, what what is confusing about that? according
to Queen and Nick had previously told him that he doesn't care
about what he says if he obviously wants to say he won't stop
engaging >> showing what are they arguing about
and then Nick >> all about Nicholas Yorio running away
from criticism okay >> okay so maybe that statement was
wrong but it's this still isn't like confusing right like yeah
turns out you like swear and yell at people all the time will
talk to you >> cuz from what I've heardman's arguments
they're not so out of this realm of insane these are like basic
things that other people in the community other people in the
space are starting to agree with starting to think on their own
and sudden and Nick won't engage with them at all. If these were
wrong, if these were so wrong, the Nick of like two, three years
ago would have just stamped them in the mud right there.
>> Okay. When you say his arguments, are you talking about
like his stream or something? Because like just go look at his
Twitter like Queen are they're direct like he's not saying anything.
He's just like saying you're you're a or whatever. He's not making
any arguments. Maybe he has like live streams of
>> and from and his basically the crux of his uh arguments.
I haven't I haven't watched the streams. I've only talked to
Queenman, but this is what he's told me is that he believes that
Nick has sold out on his principles in order to kind of ride
Ethan Klein's tale. And he gave a few examples. I don't know.
I don't have the examples here because like I said, I don't really
follow the content. I'm looking at what Nick's not doing and
how he's acting, right? But the things that Queman said to me
at the time didn't seem out of this world insane. And I think
he owes it to the audience. I think he owes it to Cleman. I think
he owes it to everyone to debate him. When he promoted him for
a year, he watched him attack other people. He watched Cleveland
go off on others. He watched him destroy Boax. But now all of
a sudden it's pointed out at him. He's completely refusing to
engage, saying, "Oh, this is gay. You're being gay. I'm not gonna
this isn't even worth my time." Like that is woman talk. That's
not how Nick Diorio should act, especially as a commentator.
Okay. So, like maybe there is some very
hyper advanced and and you know smart criticisms on his multi-ourong
live streams, but don't you see like how that's like an issue
of that about how he's like d like basically deranged on Twitter.
Like you have to admit he's like he's not doing anything >> with
him when he was deranged on
>> Nick went in there knowing that and he still promoted
still said that he's internet friend that snuck in. >> Stale
is flubbing it. I messaged Stale to come on stream. I want Stale
on stream right now. >> If somebody's deranged to you though,
you're going to you're going to stop doing that. Like like
>> I didn't even notice left the he left the Discord. He
should come out. >> Previously told by Nick that he would
love to talk to and that he wouldn't get mad or like get out
or whatever. And if the arguments are true, and I'm sure Nick
has some idea of what saying, >> he's not making arguments
on Twitter. >> We're not talking about Twitter. We're talking
about
these are streamers. These people stream. But all he's doing
is arguing on Twitter. He's going to ple and say and he's replying
to Stardust threads and saying, "Well, you know, I'm not I'm
not going to engage with that guy who's mean to my friends. I
didn't like what he said about Willie." Well, then talk to him
about what he said about Willie. Talk to him about what he said
about Tommy. Talk to him about what he said about you. You promoted
him for a year. You watched him do this to other people. If he's
that bad, I think you owe it to your audience to now explain
why you're disavowing and prove that you're disavowing for a
valid reason.
>> Especially if you're a commentator. commentator his
whole opinion. >> It's discussion.
>> I I mean all I'm saying is like looking at the at least
the things that I'm seeing maybe the Twitter is the reason. Like
don't you think that would be like a bad idea? >> Twitter's
not the reason like if you have all these >> Twitter's
not the reason. >> Okay. Well, okay. That that that's all
I had to say at least is is I just think he's deranged on Twitter
and I would not be surprised if somebody doesn't want to interact
with somebody like that. >> While he was being apparent,
he hasn't changed how he acts on Twitter. He's Queen has been
the same for the past year. He's a bit mean and he he uh has
streams. He's a bit mean on Twitter. He means on Twitter, but
Nick was friends and promoted him while he was doing that. It's
not a valid argument. It's just all I can see it as is Nick is
running. That's it. >> Or maybe Yeah. Like maybe you you
can be friends with somebody if they're not attacking you. Okay,
whatever. That's it. That's all he had. But >> wait, wait,
hold on. Wait. >> Oh, yeah. >> Quan requested to
speak. Would you be willing to talk to Quman? >> No, I'm
not going to talk to Cleman. Is it
cuz I'm a regular
but you're >> he can talk about me, right? He he'll probably
do some some nonsense. Whatever. But >> I don't I don't
want to serve your opinion cuz I broadly agree with them. But
you obviously have opinions that you don't agree with. You said,
>> you know, if he makes a video, I'll respond to the video.
Okay. >> Wait, but why not talk to him right >> I
don't do live talks like that. Uh when someone Okay. >> You
talk to me. Damn. Well, >> that's that that was a waste
waste of
This is >> he was being really mean to me on Twitter, but
he didn't really much. >> He said, "Why are you guys so
butt mad that that what Nick won't give you attention? Maybe
you guys are just >> Did you comment
by the way? >> You have Isn't like the whole point of being
a commentator though is like trying to get to the truth and actually
trying to like, you know, call out other people on their actions.
>> That should be the point, right? >> Yeah. Yeah.
So, like the whole point is also just like discussion and Nick
has not been like afraid of doing that. And it's not like his
friends have been afraid of doing that. I mean, >> give
me a second. I'm going to go get some water. I just told Stardust
uh if she wants to come on stream, I'll talk to her right now
oneonone. >> Hey, look. All right. To say I'm I'm a voice
of the people. I'm a voice of the
>> Just Nicole.
>> Yo, what's up? I'm uh I'm live right now. I forgot I
had requested to speak.
>> What's up? Uh, obviously >> Nick could name a
criticism that he thinks is bad faith or he thinks is disingenuous
or wrong,
>> right? He hasn't done so. He just says, "Well, I think
it's like really gross and and weird." >> He has no criticism.
He has nothing to say. So, he will not respond to Queen. He will
not talk to him >> and that's just all it is. So, not really
much else to say. >> Ah, not really much else to say. So,
thanks for having me on. I go back to
Have a have a good day. Just >> I totally I was about to
walk away. God damn it.
>> Not really much else to say. So me on. Let me go back
to listening.
>> Have a have a good day. >> Listen, if anyone else
would like to call in, the stage is yours. The floor is yours.
This is a
place of the people.
>> Blue, hop on. >> Spurgey Central wants to call
in. I don't know who Spurgey Central is, but I like the name.
Stop.
>> Okay, hold on. >> That's why we got off Twitch.
>> How we doing, [__] >> That's why we
got off Twitch. That's why we got off Twitch. We totally disavow
that language. That is why we got off >> I'm such a nice
>> That is why we're on kick only right now, okay? Cuz
Jesus Christ, guys, >> the people I give it back. I Everything
>> Oh, wait. Did I do live go live on Twitch? Oh, I did.
>> What you do is you come in here and you
>> my generosity
>> by saying by spending live on Twitch and not giving
your opinion. This is a place for people to speak.
this guy wants in. Hello,
this guy. How you doing?
>> listen to these these dudes for like two seconds. I'm
trying to see if we're getting other people on stream or not
right now. >> How you feeling about all this? >> So,
look, my >> I invited Stardust on the stream. I said if
she wants to be here, she could be
>> They're flip-flopping with him. >> Okay, we're
off Twitch now. We're actually off Twitch now.
>> Come on. the first stream he did on Dan when Dan was
>> oh this guy's so this guy's a total
>> like a a gr uh immoral and then he's like buddy buddy
with him >> you know >> oh well like him buddying
up with Dan afterwards yeah I agree >> this guy should
hop on stream we should >> you're going to go on like a
six-mon spur of Destiny content and then you're going to pair
up with an extension of Destiny which is what Dan is by the way
Dan is nothing without DGG online that like this isn't like Dan
isn't like oh this is like Destiny's friend but like he has his
own eye like no >> Dan is directly completely >> why
didn't you just stay on the panel I should have maybe but >> and
like >> I'm trying to get other people to come talk to
me >> to DG to D to Destiny which is why he still does
a show with him which is why he went around doing kind of like
a tour for Destiny when the [__] first started coming
out kind of like giving him like defending him but also trying
to plate to the people who were against him but like being like
oh well you know Maybe maybe Destiny thought this or that. Like
he's doing >> I'm literally telling Stardust she can come
talk to me right now. Just talk about this drama. >> You
can't like
>> you can't be you can't you can't be friends with Dan
do a podcast with Dan
>> and then >> if you want to do the AHD content
for the rest of his channel, I don't really care. But the Dan
Sand really put me off because he was like so aggro with Dan
at the start of the Pixie drama and then just doing that parade
with him on live like nothing ever happens.
>> Yeah, I agree. I I saw Smaggle saying that too. Smaggle
was like, "Bro,
now that it's all over, can we all agree that was a" Which, you
know, look, Smaggle Smaggle, but I think he had a point there.
>> He's right unfortunately.
Who else wants in? You let me tell you the options I have right
now. I have Cinematications who is telling a fanfiction.
I have I have the fake Yeet account who's now named themselves
Star and put Stardust as their profile picture trying to trick
me into thinking that they're Stardust. Jokes on you. I wouldn't
talk to Stardust anyways. And then I have Butch Nathaniel, which
is dumbass. And
>> and now Spurge Central wants >> Where are we on
Twitter? Oh, there's a big drama going on. We're letting dumb
asses [__] >> Hello. Can you hear me? >> Dumb
asses.
>> If people do want to call in, they can. I think I'm
just trying to see if will talk to me for two seconds. >> Go
ahead. Go.
>> Go ahead. >> All right. I just wanted to say real
quick, uh, >> I think Poser is a better host for Twitter
spaces. You are stupid gay white >> God, it's like only
trolls. Oh well.
Uh, I'd take call-ins on this, guys. If we want to do call-ins,
you can join the waiting room. I'll take call-ins on this. If
people want to talk about it, I'm going to sit in this Colins's
channel. I'll be right back. I'm just going to get a drink real
quick. Not Kathy L. True. I'm just trying to see if I can get
anybody who wants to come and support Nick here,
guys. We are all on the hunt for a person who wishes to support
Nicholas Dioro in this. Okay, everybody's on the hunt. We haven't
found anybody except Stale. Okay, we're all on the hunt for somebody
who wants to take his side on this. Anybody? Can we get anybody?
Is there anybody? That's what we're looking for. Anyone? God,
there's nobody here. Let me pull. So, this was before the debate
she had with Destiny. I hope she understands that what she did
to this person. That's exactly what Destiny did to her, right?
Still's in your Discord. What? Oh, let's go. Oh, hold on though.
Hold on. I need to I need to protect this room. Okay, I got it
down. Jesus. What's up, Stale? How's it going? Sorry, I shifted
I shift the room size down. I didn't want to have a bunch of
other people call in because I know you said I said oneonone.
>> guy, he limited the call-in channel for stale so people
couldn't ambush him. Well, you might watch this tonight as well,
by the way. Stale 2000. Do we know Stale 2000? Obviously, he
I believe runner up DJ of the year. Um, longtime DG moderator,
recently live stream fails head moderator. Where's one of his
videos? He did his campaign video for DJ of the Year. >> Hi,
I'm Everyone must know this, right? Hi, I'm Stale 2000 and I'm
running for DGER of the year on December the 3. In this video,
I'm going to be talking So that that's Stale. So Stale called
into the Twitter space that Alex Gekkma hosted and was was talking
very negatively of me. Talking very negatively, being like, "What?
Why is Nick has to talk to Queen? Queen is unhinged. Obviously,
I've had I don't blame Stale." Okay, I really seriously I don't
blame Stale for hating me at all. I have been very mean to Stale.
All right. I've had a couple of conversations with him. I did
shout at him. I did insult him. I I have been I've been a little
bit crazy towards Stale, I will admit. So, I don't blame Stale
for not liking me, but he was just giving this like absolute
take where it's like, well, yeah, when people are mean to your
friends, you're not going to want to talk to them. It's like,
bro, you're missing the whole the whole point here that the whole
thing it's commentary. Nick is big on self-p policing. like all
these obvious indicators. It's like, yeah, if you were like talking
about friends at a workplace in real life or friends that you
go down the pub with or friends from college.
Yeah, that would make sense. It doesn't make sense here though,
does it? It doesn't make any sense here. So, that's it's kind
of what keeps falling back to that. And he calls into Jook stream
after being on the Twitter space. Yeah, I'm about to say that.
Jto. He joins Juk stream um after being on the Twitter space.
And Jay Stalk locks the little VC where his like main VC for
talking to people on stream. He locks it. So I can only have
two people in there. So I kind of have Stale and him in there.
And so I just start spam joining like the VC above and the VC
below. The one that Stale's talking to Jay talking just like
spamming bouncing back and forwards between the two. And Stale
freaks the out on stream and he's like see I'm not talking to
that guy. I'm not talking.
It was so funny. It was so good. It was so good. So we might
watch that in a bit. We have a look at that. I actually wasn't
going to try and join join and talk to him. I I was like I don't
I don't care to talk to Stale. It's like whatever. It's whatever.
How's it going? >> So doing all right. I I guess yes, I
can just give you my my position. I uh So I'm less of a Nick
defender and more of a queen and hater and Okay. See now I'm
not going to talk to this guy like Okay, he's doing the thing.
>> I know. I know. He's just being
>> He's just he's unhinged. He's an unhinged schizophrenic
man. Okay. You don't have to talk to him. I'll I I got
>> My position is that that guy is deranged at least on
Twitter. Uh like even like I've had interactions with this this
guy like like and he just immediately goes crazy. Like I'll like
try to talk to him on substance
and then he'll just like go dang. And the idea that people wouldn't
want to talk to this guy should be completely unsurprising to
any normal person. I just say like, you know, maybe this is bad
form in the commentary community to not talk to Dre Taters or
something or like to not debate people when you're fighting.
But
>> what can I say?
>> The bad form I would say in the commentary community
is if somebody has a legitimate criticism,
>> sorry, if somebody has a criticism and you want to say
they're deranged, you can point out why the criticism is deranged
or failing, you don't even have to talk to them directly. I'd
say Quimman's laid out a bunch of actual direct criticisms and
you could just respond to them directly, right? But you should
you should talk to them directly if you're going to constantly
say that they're bad faith in some way. If you're going to say
they're disingenuous, if you're going to imply they're disingenuous,
you should actually talk to them, right? I mean, is there substance
even so like what would this guy do? Like like cuz you because
you clearly can't just like read a tweet because none of these
tweets have substance. I guess like what Nicholas Stoyor should
go over his live streams and then like >> none of no no.
you just go have a conversation directly. Uh Nicholas, they were
they were like friends until I don't know a month ago. They were
just friends. They could have just talked. The people tried to
set up talks between them and Nicholas just said, "No, I'm not
going to talk." There was no deranged. There's no insanity. There's
nothing like that. Right. >> I mean, does Queman in debates
ask anything like he does on Twitter or something like like why
would you talk to somebody like that? >> Queman's like
exacting in his debates. I would say he's looking to actually
get to the heart of the issue most of the time. he starts getting
unhinged when people start dodging the actual like issue at hand.
Right? If you're if you're not responding, you're not engaging
at all, then he will start getting unhinged. So, from what I've
experienced, he's never gotten unhinged first before ever getting
into any substance at all.
>> I'll even like I'll accept that even for for the sake
of argument because I haven't really looked into it. I'm just
saying like if that's really the case, the whole dichotomy of
of being this exacting debate person and then also just being
deranged on Twitter, I don't think that that
I don't think that's a good way of advertising that.
>> Or really, can you think of anybody else in the entire
planet of Earth who has a similar profile who you could advertise
that way exactly? Who might have built a massive audience off
of doing exactly
>> Sure, I get I get your point there. But even then, like
I feel like he Destiny like does substance on Twitter too. Like
it's it's not it's like if you're doing like a three or four
line back and forth presumably you should say something of substance.
You shouldn't just be like
like even like recently like is there anything in his recent
I believe this is sure sure. So I totally agree with you that
you should do substance rights laid out the substance of this
multiple times. He might not have done so here because most of
the people in these communities engaging in like this back and
forth would know it. He might not have laid out precisely what
his criticisms are of Nicholas, but Nicholas is aware of what
his criticisms are, right? Nicholas's good friend Auggie tried
to set up a de debate between him and Nicholas, between sorry,
Queman and >> Okay. I'm just saying like has he done like
I mean probably some videos or something. It's just it would
be nice for somebody who's like not cuz I am not in this commentary
community. It'd be nice for somebody who's not like so deep in
in every in all of this to like have some context here when all
I just see as a normal person is just just drain stuff. But that's
that's all I have. I don't know. I don't know what else to >> Sure.
If I could restrain Queman, okay, if I could make him not be
totally unhinged, would you talk to him for two seconds? I'm
sure he could walk you through some of the criticisms he has
like in a calm way. >> He can uh
>> Nah, I'm not going to do that. Sorry. I just think that
he shouldn't be as strange on Twitter cuz he he was strange to
me. I tried engaging with him and then it just immediately attack
whatever. But yeah, that's it. That's all I had.
>> I think Sorry, hold on. I Okay, he's he left. God damn
it. So, the issue is in the commentary community again, your
your criticisms are everything. If you're going to malign someone
else's criticisms, if you're going to say they're bad faith,
they're not actually engaging in good faith, they're they're
lying, they're disingenuous, you say something like that, you
have to do something about it, right? You have to you have to
point to examples. You have to actually provide evidence. People
shouldn't just let you skate on, well, these people are really
unhinged and obsessed
and then there's no questions asked. I tried to get Queenman
in here. You guys missed it if you weren't looking at the Discord.
Clemen hopped around this channel. He just kept joining channels
adjacent to the channel I'm in right now over and over again.
And still was like, I'm not talking to this guy. I'm not talking
to him.
Ah, good times. All right. So, I don't know. We could we could
analyze St's statement there, right? Well, you're unhinged on
Twitter, so you shouldn't be shocked. Nobody wants to talk to
you. It's like, that's fine, but what is the bar here, right?
The bar is destiny.
No.
Is Quimman more unhinged than Destiny on Twitter? Could he just
not agree with the criticism and not want to debate it? Yeah,
he could not agree with the criticism, but he is he is literally
saying the criticism is like wrong. He's not just saying he doesn't
he doesn't agree. He's So I believe it was that it was gross
and what's the exact quote?
Gross and unfair, right? Unfair means it's like not genuine,
right? That it's like it's So unfair could mean not genuine or
it could mean the bar is way too high. So you could defend either
of those points. Uh Nick tried to defend that point that the
bar was way too high. People had bar for Willie way too high
for what they expected and he got absolutely dogwalked by Auggie
on stream trying to make that exact point. Right. We know this
is a purely click thing. It is. It is more or less a click thing.
Yes. I just thought listen I just thought it'd be cool to get
somebody who wanted to defend this. If he's just going to go
oh well you can't be mean on Twitter and engage. Probably the
best response to that would actually be okay. You can't be mean.
You could have that that exact opinion, but then you have to
explain why Nicholas would get on a live stream with Destiny
and get talked to about January 6th for 6 hours, right? I think
most people expect Destiny to match Energy. Queen doesn't do
that. He goes for broke. That's just not true. Queen's perfectly
fine matching energy. He matches energy all the time. He only
gets unhinged when people will not answer when people like there's
basically a tit for tat that happens in debates where you engage
with points the other person makes and vice versa. And as soon
as the other person stops engaging at all, Queen will start talking.
I think Destiny's very similar. You ever watch Destiny debate
a conservative? That's Queen most debates.
Hangingler, I think you're just upset that you got told to eat
Tide Pods by the British kid.
No offense. No offense. No offense. Wait, so Destiny tweets are
cool, but Queen is the unhinged one? Well, I don't think Nicholas
thinks Destiny tweets are cool anymore, but he did for a while,
which I'm not that's not a criticism in and of itself. It's just
a point to, hey, even if Queen's like unhinged on Twitter or
something, that doesn't mean you wouldn't engage with this person,
right? I'm sure he's engaged with a lot of really really mean
people in the past. I'm sure that's happened. He's learning from
Destiny on a topic he didn't know the details of. Yeah, but I
think he was he was like I think he was um not looking to turn
down any conversations either. Like if if Destiny had wanted
to have an argument with Nicholas, he wouldn't have turned it
down.
Obviously, Kingler, you could say, "Nobody is going to say, Queen
will not come in here and say, "Hey, Normie should debate me
after I talked about uh how Nicholas Dioro is." Quan won't say
that. Nicholas operates in a space where he does a segment called
ultimate review. Okay? He doesn't get to he doesn't have the
same bar for hingedness as the average person. You don't get
to do that that excuse. You can't say, "Oh, this is really weird
how you guys engage." You can't do that, right?
Did I say I met Nick? Yes, Nick doesn't get to do that. He runs
Ultimate Review. He doesn't get to say, "Oh, you talked about
how somebody was I don't want to engage with you." "Oh, you were
really unhinged. I don't want to engage with you." That's not
a fair That's not a fair deflection. Lots of people around him
are unhinged.
Can be unhinged. And I don't even buy that Queman's that unhinged
most of the time anyway. He's not a debater. He's a streamer.
Not the same thing. Queman's not a When is Queman like an infamous
debater? He He is a total debate, but is he like infamous for
Not really. It's not like like he streamed by himself all the
time. He is a total debate, but he the thing about Queen is
okay, this is just from my experience. When you actually engage
with him on the substance, he will just walk through and do substance
with you. Right. Right. I've never had a debate with Queenman
where we're going back and forth on substance and he will throw
in a jab to like throw me off or he'll debate tactic in some
way. If he thinks you're having a discussion on merits, he will
just have that discussion. He's much more engaged in my experience
in having that discussion, right? Hey, I just want to talk back
and forth. What I've never what I've seen a lot of is people
start not engaging. They start not they start either willfully
or unintentionally not listening and then he gets upset, right?
And then he starts talking. That's that's my experience with
him. I have not had any other experience. If other people can
give me times where he's just been totally unhinged and deranged
the whole time, go ahead. My only criticism of Quean is the constant
dead air. That's what most people say. It's very
I see Quan's attack on Nicholas Yuri is going about as well as
his attack on O 20,000 did. Influencers. No influence will always
be funny. See you someday. This is somebody with no vision. Okay.
Can't see the vision. Blinded. Blinded. He's old. He's got cataracts.
He's blinded. He can't see the vision. He doesn't see where where
it's going at all. Okay.
Unfortunate.
Unlucky.
embarrassing
influencers with no influence coming from Tommy C is the glassiest
house ever. Well, to be fair, Tommy C does have very like possibly
influential friends, right? I wouldn't say he has no influence,
just not through his audience.
Is that Tommy implying O is an influencer? Yes, O is an influencer.
He's got a big big Twitter account. He gets to influence people
against us on at least, right? How will Queen survive this? Well,
the the funny thing is is
people talk about how like these channels are dead. They're going
to die. They're all It's all over for them, right? Get Sipman
to call in. Oh, that would be good. Hold on. Yes. Yes. Oh, this
guy's not friends with me. I'm not in any joint servers.
I just added him as a friend.
We'll see. That would be good.
Sman won't join. Why not, dude? I like Do I need to I need to
use Twitter more cuz I I swear to God, Twitter is like where
you find these people. Oh, yeah. Exframe. That was what I was
about to say. It's like people are always like, "Oh, your channel's
going to die. Your channel's going to die. You're not around
like this person. You don't you don't connect with this person.
You're going to die." And it's like, "Dude, I I get views without
those connections." Like, I feel comfortable. I don't have to
I don't have to just be nice to people because I need these network
opportunities to climb and just come on do the show. It's all
fine.
Used to be in the server. Yeah, he used to be in the server.
He's not anymore. I added him. We'll see if he wants to come
on. I just want again, we're all looking for that guy. We're
all looking for the legitimate guy who will come on and defend
Nicholas. Where is one? Where is just one one guy? I don't know.
Queen looks like he's 6 months away from AIDS finally taking
him. Okay. It's kind of weird how stagnant Queman is subscriber-wise,
but has such an active fan base. I don't know what's going on
with that. Yeah. Yeah. Exto. I mean, the thing about drama content
and drama content creators is they will be stagnant between periods
before stuff pops off, right? It's you grow from like these big
pop off moments. You don't grow from like consistently. You don't
really grow the same way a lot of other channels grow. You have
like big popoff moments where you gain like a big chunk of people
and then it's like sort of a slow bleed or a stagnation until
the next big popoff moment. You don't really It's not like a
steady build over time. Like if you run a uh what would it be
like? Um say you ran like a book channel, right? You do like
this steady growth over time. It's all about popping off. Anyway,
uh did Stardust respond to me? That's what I'm looking for. I
literally said, "Hey, just hop on the stream. Just come talk."
Oh, man. Go through Day's tweets replies. Um, what's the site
uh what's the site you use to look at Twitter
like without a login? Does anyone know it off the top of your
head? Someone want to link me that site really quickly because
I want to go through some replies. We'll see what people are
saying here. Is it knitter? X cancel is what I'm looking for.
X cancel. Not Nitter anymore. X cancel. Let me do Let me go take
a look here. I'm just looking to see we get I'm just looking
to see if we get responses here on any of the Nicholas tweets,
right? But we don't have like a lot of responses on his tweets.
Let me go look. He's moved on. He's moved on. He's moved on.
Dude, he's I just think he's like not going to get much of anything
from people, right? If Stardust joins, allow Queen to moderate.
If Stardust joins, I'd give her like oneonone time if that's
what she wants. Hold on. I'm just looking for anything here.
I I'll I'll go and I'll find where people are defending Nicholas
in any of these replies and I'll message those people individually
if they want to come on. I don't want Sardis to talk to Queenman.
Stardust just said, "Oh no, she keeps doing this like guning
session thing." I was like, "Literally, join right now. It'll
be oneonone.
That's all you got to do. Just join right now. It'll be oneonone.
It's totally fine." Hold on. Hold on. What?
Like anyone takes anything you say seriously after the massive
gunk guarding session you and your friends had on stream law
off. I'm not in this. You're welcome on my stream live right
now for another guning session. No thanks. We'll not be tuning
in. I'll let you in so we can speak oneonone. I don't hate myself
to subject myself to it. Or I don't hate myself enough to subject
myself to it. But thanks.
Like what are we doing? What are we doing here? Like I I'm literally
just sitting here. Yeah, I'll talk to you. You hop on? Sure.
Apparently not. Yeah. After all the posturing h
you literally subjected yourself to a call. True. Oh my god.
She did she did go to like farr right spaces and get called all
kinds of slurs.
I'm not even looking to debate. She wanted to talk and she was
like, "Oh, I don't want a guning session." I just pulled stale
in. None of that there. Well, what else do we got? I'm not I'm
not seeing anyone who wants to come on. What are my criticisms
of Nick? My criticisms of Nick would be, hey, you have people
that you say you respect, you say you respect their opinion,
but you won't talk to them about criticisms they have, and then
when your when your friends offer to moderate and have a conversation
about it, you also dodge that, and then you say that their criticisms
are what? Gross and unfair.
I think that that seems unfair to me when you're going to comment
on it publicly. If you want to hide publicly, you want to just
hide and lock it down, do a fortress arc like Vos, that's totally
fine, I guess. I mean, I I don't really like it for a commentary
YouTuber personally, but if you want, don't comment on it publicly.
Don't make those comments publicly.
That's all. So, Drama 101, if you got anything beyond that, go
ahead. We'll see if we got anyone looking to call in right now.
Nobody in the waiting room. Nobody at all. Did Did Sman answer?
Someone said they tried.
I'll talk to Dude, I'll talk to anyone about this. Like, let's
go.
Didn't he say the amount of crit criticism Will he was getting,
not just criticism? Okay, but like that could be fair, but then
why is he cutting off people? Why is he cutting off creators?
Because the audiences don't like what the creators are saying.
Can anyone from chat call in? You can tamer Nigel. Yes.
If I don't get Did we unmute Kathy? Because if if we didn't unmute
Kathy, I feel like Cathy's got new accounts to try and get me
here. What are your criticisms of Quean?
Um, probably my only criticism of Quimman would be that sometimes
he is a little bit too aggressive when people are not understanding
him or not engaging with him. But honestly, I've only seen that
after like most people get very frustrated. Okay. He doesn't
like wasting time.
Play devil's advocate and make arguments for Nick. Well, I can't
I It's hard to make arguments for Nick if he's going to complain
about some of these things publicly. It just is. That's just
facts. All right.
Hold on. Never mind. I don't want Simman here. Now, this is maybe
the most embarrassing response. So, Hellbent asked him, "Hey,
hey, hey, hey, do you uh you should call in. You should call
in. You should call in." All right.
And he says, "Tell him to send all the money I paid him over
the year and back." And I will,
brother.
Is there any more comment than this? I paid that guy a whole
bunch of money. I Are you serious? I
It's sad. It's embarrassing.
It's disappointing. Oh well. Just to be clear, everyone on Oreo's
side realiz this is a [__] meltdown. What's the lore
here? This guy used to donate a lot of money to me and he does
not do that anymore. I think he left around the time Nicholas
did. He kind of like broke hard with Nicholas and Willie. So,
your argument is Nick is kind of Nick isn't obligated to talk
to Queenman, but I'd say he's like obligated to respond to criticism.
And I think he's obligated to not sort of um malign his critics
without engaging.
It's it's very cowardly in my opinion to say these guys are bad
faith, these guys are obsessed, they're unhinged, they're they're
wrong, they're disingenuous, they lie, they slander people, which
is not necessarily what Nick says, but what people in his community
say. And then to never engage back, right? You don't you don't
get to force engagements with people. That's not what anyone's
saying. Okay? It's saying that if you want to if you want to
actually take shots at at that criticism or that critic, then
you should either be willing to engage or just admit that you
you're scared to. Right? Like the the admission by him not responding
by him saying, "Oh, I'm done with this. It's really gay." Is
just saying, "I'm scared to talk to this person because they
have valid criticism." You might have to No, I don't ambush people
like that. Curyoko, you don't get anyone to ever call in again
if you ambush them over, right? It's ridiculous. One second.
Honestly, don't know what the argument was for either of them
to begin with, so I'm lost. Okay, so the argument from the beginning
was Nicholas was being sort of disingenuous, not following his
principles in some cases, covering the H3 drama that he wouldn't
that if you know, if Ethan was doing something wrong, Nicholas
would either start criticizing the people criticizing him and
ignore it or he would like soften the criticism pretty hard,
right? That's that is like broadly what it is to continue this
like jerk wave against the H3 critics. You think this is the
best response we will get from Nick? His stream chat will have
questions. He'll just ban them and he can. He's got like a very
big community, right? He doesn't have to actually respond. He
doesn't want to. Queen called him a child. Well,
listen. I think uh I think Queen just doesn't like getting ignored.
Okay. What are you What are you supposed to do, man? What are
you supposed to do? All right, anyone? If you're uh if you're
looking to join, you can join. But I'm going to move on to other
stuff here or I will I'll keep
I'll see if there's more. We'll we'll pepper this in throughout
the night. But we should start going on to some other content
piece here real quick cuz
otherwise we'll just be sitting here watching Twitter and that's
no fun. Could he just not hate Hassan more than dislike what
Ethan's doing? Yeah. But I would say if you have principles against
the things Ethan's doing to people he's critics of or sorry to
people who are critical of him, then you should probably point
that out, right? Like somewhere around the time where Ethan risks
more or less like almost all commentary channels in some way.
Sorry, commentary streaming channels by by forming his lawsuit.
I think you have to start actually going and like criticizing
back. Dan Alman is surely to blame. I don't think Dan's to blame,
man. Why? Why do people just do this and then run? Of how Hog
Dirt inserted herself, then ran when invited to discuss on stream.
Many such cases. Did you see Destiny complaining about you covering
Kyla Maxwell for 6 hours?
Wait, wait, was he was he complaining about the the un the America
coverage or the debate coverage? The debate coverage. I see here's
the thing. I was totally fair to Kyle in the debate coverage.
I said where she was making good points, right?
I I pointed out that Destiny could not mount a single like actual
tangible argument against what she was saying that he just totally
failed the whole
Posted the entire VOD in DG chat. No time stamp at all. Awesome.
There's nothing but NYSE obsession.
I Dude, Unfortunately, it's not my fault that just watching NYSE
argue on TikTok uncut is hilarious.
That's not my fault. Just a warning. When communities become
like this, it's only a matter of time until they do gay spam
reporting. I don't know what you're warning me from. I would
say you could easily just go and find arguments where I'm incorrect
in the uh in any of my coverage. There sure is a lot of it. He's
desperate to not admit she's a complete doofus. Not many orbiters
remain. I mean,
that Destiny comment was pretty rough. What if I told you that
Destiny says that Kyla or not so aerodite is like really good
at debate and like does a really good job? What if what what
if, guys? What if I told you that? What What would you think
if I told you that that was the case? God,
we technically have more of that stuff today and now I'm tempted
to cover it. Wait, does somebody have the uh the obsession thing?
Where's the obsessed thing? Is that just DG chat or is that somewhere
else? I would love if we could just if he commented on and said
something about being obsessed. I would love to see it. He said
you only cover her because Cherry is obsessed with her. It's
in DGG.
well, I could have sworn like two months ago. Not so Erdite said
I was the most obsessed hater she had, which really is a disservice
to Queen in that case, right? But I think I think she was saying
I was like the most unhinged hater, the most like disingenuous
person towards her that existed. So that's crazy again. And it
doesn't matter who you bounce the obsession to, right? Like the
clips, go look at the clips Cherry posted. They stand for themselves.
It doesn't matter who posts them. They're funny on their own.
Like all of these Oh Jesus. All of these clips are just funny
on their own. >> We're trying to recruit you. >> Based
in what? I haven't said anything.
>> You said that Steven was intelligent. That is lowkey
based.
>> He is. You don't you don't debate and not have like
a high level of intelligence or like an understanding of how
those types of conversations work.
>> What if I told you >> his job literally requires
his intelligence? I wouldn't deny that. >> What if I told
you that Steven regularly has said that Kyla or not so aerodite
is really good at debate.
>> Sorry, I actually kicked the clip, didn't I? I was sorry.
Sorry. Uh that was I
>> Steven regularly has said the clip or not so aerodite
is really good at debate and does a really good job.
>> they just all start laughing. >> I I don't as
he >> they just all start laughing. They all start Dude,
that's that's like not my fault. I didn't make her say that.
Okay, you could say it's obsessed to point out how funny that
is, but it's not. It's literally just hilarious. That's not my
fault. That's not Cher's fault. That's not anybody's fault except
Aronites. She's the one who said it. Oh, sorry. This was uh Tell
them to send back the money. This is the Sentman thing. Well,
what was that again that made you regret the patronage?
Uh you literally took a pick and sent it to Jtock. Yeah, it's
funny.
We love Hell Vent here. Okay, we love
uh guess he values more than the content. Money val more than
the content.
I I'm not giving you back
I just thought you know we wanted one person who could come in
and defend
the Nick position but unfortunate
some professional act like this promoting your political advocacy
group while intoxicated. H. Oh, that's a that's true, Jerry.
Before J-ST was controlling me, now I'm controlling JTO. Oh,
amazing. Amazing.
All right. What do we What do we have in the docket today? I've
got the Superman stuff. Do Am I really going to Super Oh, wait.
I have other tweets here. I think Aiden was saying he would host
the debate. We had Aiden saying he'd host the debate. We had
Smaggle.
SMA Smaggle Dagle. By the way, this is a popular guy. Okay. popular
guy in the commentary community. I don't know who to compare
him to so you guys would know him necessarily, but he's he's
very funny. Okay, he's uh he's something of like a
he's like a a evolved chatter, okay? Somewhere between a streamer
and a chatter. He's not quite a streamer, but he's somewhere
between. All right, I somewhat get Willie, but Tommy really,
even after he acted like a spur for weeks, you aren't going to
say anything about him. The Cabal must be mighty pleased, Nicholas.
So Tommy C of course going in on Chudlo Logic for no reason repeatedly.
He's a mascot. Mascot chatter. Yes. Going in for like weeks on
Chudlo Logic just making a complete ass of himself. Saying that
Nicholas is telling him these things. Saying that he's like convinced
Nicholas that Chud is a total stake. Right. Nicholas never says
anything which to everybody else signals that Nicholas obviously
cosigns those statements,
right? That Nicholas is not going to come out and say, "No, Tommy
doesn't speak for me." He obviously co-signs the statements.
Smangle is one of the few people whose DMs Nick reads while he's
live for links, etc. Yes. Oh, that is actually an important thing
to highlight. Queen be Smangle is like somebody Nicholas likes
and and has trusted and was a massive like commentary fan. He
he pushes content into every stream, right? Someone get Willie.
Yeah. Sorry, we read this. So, him turning and he's been turned
kind of like against Nicholas on this for a couple weeks now.
That's big. That's like a big deal. It's not a small
I mean, his post, this post is just recency bias. I'm talking
about when they chased him around crying that he was a drunk
or something earlier this year, but this is actually, it's funny
because this very much mimics exactly what happens to like denims
and all of the people who are getting, you know, sued or attacked
by H3, right?
What we see there
is we see the creators getting blamed for the audiences and that
like a bad thing happens to somebody and then everybody who's
even remotely adjacent to that bad thing can be blamed. There's
like no separation whatsoever
because said that he talks to Smackle daily awesome but like
can we really blame like a 100 different people for CPS? Is that
is that fair to blame a 100 different people for CPS? I don't
think so. Right. And now like Queenman or me would get blamed
for people being mad at Tommy Seir Willie, I don't understand
how that could possibly be the case. Like what's going on there?
Anyway, I mean the mooching allegations from earlier this year
were funny and you don't have to cover them, but to gunk guard
like this, shameful at what you shameful at what you became become.
Shameful at what you become. I don't know what that means, but
awesome. Clearly sweeping from Smaggle. This sent guy could come
in and defend Nick. You can you can make the you can make it.
Smag
sit man. You can make the points. You can come you can be on
the stream. You make some points. You can defend this guy. Okay.
Also, I heard that you were uh defaming Aiden. What was the deal
there? Why did Sitman become an anti-fan? Uh I don't know.
Sorry. I do know. It would have been criticisms of Lily or something.
These people just take like cues from Nick. But I don't, by the
way, I won't blame Nick for that, right? Like this guy's just
a who when Nick says something he's going to like totally inhale
that opinion and make it his own. That's not Nick's fault. Nick
didn't turn this guy into like a spineless
thoughtless weirdo with no internal monologue, right? He didn't
turn this guy into a robot. This guy was always a robot. Isn't
this guy DJ? No, he's not. Man, dude, I don't want to let this
die. This could actually be good content, but seems like everybody's
running. Everybody's running all over the place. I didn't see
you play this clip from the his stream last night, so I posted
it. Oh, right. This didn't kick it off, did it, Riyle? This was
after Nicholas posted You posted this clip, right? He's been
like a Here, let's let's watch this. Let's see this.
That D was trolling last night. Willy's being a target of crazy
harassment campaign from like every other person online because
he's a normal guy. Barrage of hatred for absolutely no reason.
Maybe if Duro talked on stream with anyone but Willie and Tom,
he wouldn't be so out of touch. Willie has been like a u target
of like a crazy harassment campaign from like every other person
online. This feels like, >> just to be clear, and I was
I was very clear about this. I didn't go after Willie. I stopped
talking about him on stream. I had one stream where I responded
to that Auggie debate and I kind of like got annoyed. One stream
and then I went radio silent on Willie for like months
because Chud came to me and said, "Hey, we don't want to like
keep this fight going. We don't like I don't we we don't want
this fight. Just don't do it right now." Right? I was like totally
radio silent. totally radio song. I I don't I just don't get
it. I really don't. Isn't this Willie comment in relation to
the bad empanada doxing stuff? I don't know what that's about.
But I think um
I don't think so because why would it be >> Willie has
been like a target of like a crazy harassment campaign from like
>> I could have sworn in one of these I could have sworn
in one of these tweets he talked about >> person online.
It feels >> Yeah. He'd been talking the somebody accused
um he accused someone of recency bias. Smaggle of recency bias,
right? And he's like, "Oh, it goes back way before this, right?"
>> Like, because he's a normal guy who has normal guy takes
who posts like I don't even want to say surface level, but great
introductory videos for average people to watch on terminally
>> He's talking about the first video, right? This is just
his defense of the first video. This is exactly the defense he
brought to Auggie. So, no, it's not talking about the recent
stuff. Um, and there's just like this barrage of hatred this
guy gets for like absolutely no reason because he gets like minor
things wrong in videos occasionally, which makes his entire backlog
apparently like the worst content ever. So, he's getting it from
like uh anti- Destiny people. He's getting it from Hassan's people.
He's getting it from commentary channel. No, no, no. King of
Sora. I'm getting the timeline wrong. I I do this sometimes.
I think Chad asked me after I had an argument with Nicholas.
But from there, like I when we had that debate with Willie, I
didn't think it was like that big a deal. I I had that talk with
Willie. That's like a regular string conversation with me with
so many people. I didn't realize like Willie was going to take
that personally, right? I had no idea. >> I have I do not
understand the Willie Max show hatred. Willie is It wasn't even
hatred at first. It was like, "Hey, here's like some criticisms."
And that that had to blow up into like massive for some reason.
I was being consiliatory after the fact. And I offered to talk
to Nick and I was like, "Hey, I understand why you think the
like my criticisms were bad here. I'll I'll like talk to you
about them."
But it just didn't happen.
This Willie Clip is going to bite him in the ass. Sounds like
another John Son situ John Swan situation in the making. I didn't
follow that so much. But more recently, you did say you hated
Willie. Yeah, I absolutely hate Willy Mack now. There will never
be peace between me and Willy Mack, but it's for like different
personal reasons, so you guys don't have to worry about it. Oh,
no. I I absolutely hate Willie Mack now, but I It's for like
totally justified personal reasons. Chad didn't side with them.
No, no, no, no, King of Sorry. You're misunderstanding. He was
just like, "Hey, this seems like the wrong time to have an argument
with each other, like to invite over nothing." It was It was
like something I was totally fine with, by the way. It wasn't
like, "Oh, I'm telling you this is the way it is." He was like,
"Hey, if I if I could like have a conversation with these people,
would you be open to this?" It was like a totally not uh It was
not like that at all. He was just He just noticed a situation
where things might get like worse and he was like, "Hey, if I
could talk to these guys, would you be open to that?"
Which I appreciated. It was like actually totally just fine and
cool. Anyway, I'm going to He has been like
target of like a crazy harassment campaign from like every other
person online. And it feels like because he's a normal guy who
has normal guy takes who posts like
uh stuff that happened in private messages, Nick. So, I'm not
going to talk about >> I don't even want to say surface
level, but great introductory videos for average people to watch
on terminally online internet drama. Um, and there's just like
this barrage of hatred this guy gets for like absolutely no reason
because he gets like minor things wrong in videos occasionally,
which makes his entire backlog apparently like the worst content
ever. So, he's getting it from like he's getting it from everybody,
guys. Literally, everybody hates Willie >> uh anti- Destiny
people. He's getting it from Hassan's people. He's getting it
from commentary channels and I have I do not understand the Willie
M show hatred.
So, I get where Nicholas is coming from where he says this, he
wants to defend his friend, but I swear to God, what he needs
to do is start grabbing like,
"Oh, this isn't even going to be good." Cuz he could grab like
the worst commentary, the worst questions, right? Or the worst
criticisms and just answer to that. But like, I would take like
a somebody more mainstream and and point out why it's bad. Point
out like what they're saying that's wrong,
right? But we never see that. We never see them grab onto criticism
and say this is wrong. Shalom. You need to not guys if you're
going to talk about anything to do with like uh doxing do that
somewhere else. Don't talk about it in my chat. Don't be okay.
Just be be cool. Don't talk about like anything to do with that
here off. Do it elsewhere. I don't want to I don't want to see
my chat. Okay. New Stardust tweet about you. Is it going to be
why she's not coming on the stream? Just to be clear, I don't
mind fighting. Oh, as someone who's being designated punching
bag of so many people in the space for years, I hate every single
one of you. And if you died, I would not feel bad at all. I hope
it's painful. Just be clear, I don't mind fighting people for
fun. If you know my history, sometimes I do that because it's
funny to me. I do mind, however, when it's malicious and I'm
not in on it. This isn't about me. But I don't know.
Okay. I
Okay. All right. All right. Okay,
brother. Okay. Okay, dude.
Is this malicious? I don't know. Oh, do we have Wait, hold on.
This is somebody who could hop on stream. Let's go.
Oh,
I thought this was going to be different. If only Dev had a take
on this. You're the only one defending Stardust. Uh, all right.
The defense was, "Hey, don't call her like fat on my stream."
That was That was the defense. I I'm not going to pretend I was
like going to bat for Stardust. I was not. It was like, "Don't
be personally insulting. Don't insult her appearance on my stream
cuz I feel like she was like nice to me when people were being
losers. But right when I uh when I got banned and people were
celebrating that, she was like, "Oh, hey, I got banned, too.
Here's like what I did." Right? I I don't get it, though. I literally
talked I said, "Hey, I'll talk to you oneonone right now." Like
I that's the whole thing. If if I don't if I bring somebody else
in while I'm talking to her one-on-one, I would look so bad.
She's totally safe. She's totally safe.
Bro, you totally saved, dog. All right.
Oh, don't go to my notifications. Jesus, I went to my notifications
for a second. That can that can be scary sometimes. Okay. People
reply with some crazy [__] on Twitter once in a while.
Stardust does not like you because of your connection with Queenman.
Yes. OMFG. He's pro. You are You never know what's going on.
I I I just have to point it out sometimes. You literally never
know what's going on. She's literally telling me that she wants
to argue with me on stream, right? She's literally like, "Hey,
you you should you should take criticism on stream." Said, "You're
welcome right now for another gunkarding session. We have like
people on to defend you. No thanks." I say, "No, no, no. You
can come on right now and I'll talk to you." I don't hate myself
enough to subject myself to it, but thanks. She's literally calling
me out for not taking criticism, and I'm like, "You're welcome
to come on right now. I won't bring somebody else in." She's
like, "No, I I won't do that." Okay. I don't like this is embarrassing.
Do you like Sunday criticized the out of you like a month ago?
Just like two weeks ago, but yes. Like no offense,
but I'm like a thousand times more concerned about talking to
Sunday about my personal life than I am talking to Stardust.
Okay. Anyway, all right. I'm looking for anything else on this
guys. If you got any other tweets or anything relevant parties
getting their takes in my way. Otherwise, I think we move on
to a piece of content here while we wait for more stuff to roll
in. Let me see
I just have a note here.
You should cover Dan stalking people still.
Dude, Dan's Twitter has been like unhinged, right? Is he not
just like downloading every single thing? He's He's like doing
his whole thing where he figures out who all of these people
are and then he's like going to all of their social media profiles
and downloading all of their from everything ever so that he
can send it all to Ethan. You read the Destiny logs? I didn't
get the Destiny logs.
Where do I at? to my way if you want. CEO of Redact, by the way.
Well, technically you could argue it's a good You could argue
it's like a good advertisement for Redact. I hate Nick and Willie
Mac so much it hurts. I don't hate like I don't have any hate
for these people. I just think well except Willy M. Sorry. Except
Willie Mack, but um I don't have any hate for these people. It's
like internet [__] It could all flip on a dime, right?
I don't I don't think Queen would have any problem with talking
like I don't think Queenman I don't think I don't think anybody
that I am remotely associated with whether or not they associate
with me anyone I'm remotely associated with I don't think any
of them would go oh if Nicholas like talks to Quean and it like
goes really well for Nicholas or something I don't think any
of them would go oh we have to cut Nick out likewise if it goes
well for Queman I don't think anybody would say oh we have to
cut Nick out like I think everybody would be totally okay with
Nick tomorrow there's like no problem right on that front oh
boy where's The It was the Jake Chinatown stuff stuff, right?
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Hold on. Where is it? Here. Where's the f first
Jake Chinatown tweet? Yeah. Well, I think Jake Chinatown's privated
now. Dan says, "Hi, I have a full archive of all of your tweets
that I saved with a third party complaint archiver to be admissible
for discovery. I'll send them all to Ethan. But hey, as you formally
said here, who would ever believe a Israeli? Maybe that will
work for you in court. Of course, this archive was collected
before you started mass deleting anything. That was just insanely
defamatory. But as I said, I have everything saved. Anyways,
the archives includes Twitter media as well as the tweet analytics,
replies, comments, views for all accounts I tracked at the time.
Here are the accounts. I suppose this will be helpful for Ethan
to prove damages when he can pull up defamatory posts from you
and also show how many times those posts were seen by others.
Shabbat shalom.
Wow, Dan's like, uh, I love that legal doxing is the meta now.
Yeah, Dan's sort of like taken doxing and he's like, actually,
I'm applying technology now.
I'm doxing, but I'm using like my software company and all of
my resources is like a software company entrepreneur to do it.
I'll pay people to make scripts. I'll pay people pay people to
like figure out Twitter. All right, we're taking we're taking
docs in. We're going big leagues with it. It's cool.
Not really. It's actually scary, but you know, we just say it's
cool. We love Dan here. I think that's one of the big disconnects
here. It's not that deep to people like you, Queenman, whereas
it's absolutely deep for Nick, Tommy, and
Uh, no though. Willie, I I don't like Willie now, but for everything
else, it's fine. Dan doesn't care about that. Dan just likes
to be a menace.
Do seem that way sometimes. All right, where do I go to find
these logs?
Desie like being uh as mad.
Give me a second
cuz if we do that, then we can cover the uh we can cover the
America Tour hot tub stream and see how that went. The prelude
to yesterday's stream. Okay. Oh, Russell Logs. Okay. Hold on.
Give me a second. Well, I just don't know. So, this guy
gets upsetty yeti in his chat sometimes.
oh. Oh, I know what this is. I know what this is. This is him
trying to pay penance. Okay. He has to make up for the fact that
he had to take away not so erodite's former like hopes and dreams
where she erodite you know a big part of her identity was I helped
fix destiny I helped get him on to to viveance I helped him treat
his ADHD
no doubt telling herself that she saved hundreds of women from
having their nudes shared non-conensually online all right they're
shared non-conensually online she believes she did all of it
and then Destiny had to take that from her and say no actually
Cherry Cherry got me to do
So now he has to make up for it. I had no idea JTOK was so pathetic.
Vaude, they do like six hour stream literally just obsessively
talking about Note. Probably because Cher's obsessed with her.
Lol. Like 80% of that VOD apparently. It's because Cherry's obsessed
with her for some reason.
Um,
it's just criticism, bro. You could address it, you could not
address it. We just watch content here and then we laugh about
it. I don't know. Some people have a big deal with this or some
people have a big problem with this apparently. No problem when
they do it to other people. Okay. Oh, come on. We all knew Jay-
Sock was this pathetic. I helped Destiny with his fashion. I'm
I'm throwing this up. Oh, wait. I can't actually do that. I was
going to throw it up. No look. Gross. I can't do that. I want
to see him react to your VOD. There's no way he can find a way
to defend it. Well, I'm sure I say Listen, I'm doing like six
hours of live commentary over something. I'm sure I say something
silly somewhere in there,
I'm sure I do. It's just Listen, it's not my fault that all of
this content is like that. It's just like a treasure trove of
cringe weirdo behavior that that we have like adults, 30-year-old
adults doing this.
It's not my fault. I didn't do the behavior. Hassan is so or
sorry, when Hassan calls me obsessed, he just means he doesn't
want to engage with the criticism. When Bosch calls me obsessed,
he just means he doesn't want to engage with the criticism,
right? We've heard this. How many times do we have to hear that?
Okay. over years and years. They just call me obsessed cuz they
can't deal with the criticism. Wow.
Vodessi says she's really good at debate. She does a She's good
at debate. She has a really good job.